ثلاث حلقات أخرى من سلسلة Harry and
Megan Netflix أسقطت
بين عشية وضحاها دوق ودوقة ساسكس
توضح بالتفصيل إجهاضهما الذي تعرض له
هاري أيضًا للانفتاح على
علاقته مع شقيقه بينما
تكشف ميغان عن صراعها مع
الأفكار الانتحارية التي تريد أن تجلبها
معلنة أنها Max Foster لدينا
مراسل ملكي ينضم إلينا واقفًا
هذا الصباح من لندن ، شكرًا لك ماكس ،
ما هي الوجبات السريعة الكبيرة وماذا
تتوقع أن يكون الرد في العائلة المالكة
جيدًا؟
أيضًا
نظرة غير عادية جدًا خلف جدران القصر
حول كيفية عمل الأشياء هناك بشكل
فعال.هاري ميغان يتهم بقية
العائلة بالغيرة منهم ثم
العمل ضدهم لفترة وجيزة
ضدهم لدرجة أن ميغان كانت لديها
أفكار انتحارية ، لذا فهي قصة مقنعة
للغاية من  وجهة نظر هاري ميغان ،
هذا هو المكان الذي تتوج فيه
حقًا بمواجهة Quee
حوزة ساندرينجهام بين هاري ويليام
تشارلز والملكة حيث
يحدد هاري خطته لمغادرة العائلة المالكة
ولكن لا يزال يواصل إلى
حد ما دورًا ملكيًا
كما تعلم أننا نحاول وضع
مخطط للمضي
قدمًا  في نفس الاقتراح
الذي كنا نعلم أنه تم طرحه علنًا ،
ولكن بمجرد وصولي إلى هناك ، تم إعطائي خمسة
خيارات ،
أحدها جميعًا بدون تغيير ، وخمسة
جميعها
، اخترت الخيار الثالث في الاجتماع
، حيث يكون لدى النصف والنصف الآخر وظائف خاصة بنا  ولكن
أيضًا العمل في دعم الملكة
ولكن سرعان ما أصبح واضحًا جدًا
أن هذا الهدف لم يكن مطروحًا للنقاش
أو النقاش
، كان أمرًا مرعبًا أن يكون أخي
يصرخ ويصرخ في وجهي ويقول والدي
أشياء لم تكن ببساطة صحيحة
جدتي التي تعرفينها تجلس بهدوء
هناك ونوعا
ما أعلم أنني كنت أتوقع رد القصر
الذي قال للتو إنهم
لن يقدموا ردًا بدلاً من ذلك ،
ستستمر العائلة في خطة طويلة
مخطط لها.  خطوبة اليوم دون